dans un pays d'un mois maintenant ce
sera le début de la Coupe du monde de
football 2022 c'est comme toujours un
des plus gros événements planétaires de
l'année et ça fait surtout de plus en
plus parler puisque ça se passe au Qatar
on dirait que tout le monde découvre
voilà un mois que ça soit ça fait 10 ans
ça fait 10 ans qu'on sait que c'est au
Qatar mais c'est maintenant tout le
monde découvre au Qatar ah bah tiens au
canards on vous parlait de la semaine
dernière de plus en plus de personnes
appelle au boycott et dans cette
situation les diffuseurs de la
compétition se retrouvent assez gênés et
ont peur de passer pour ceux qui
cautionnent donc il y a TF1 il y a une
énorme Barka ils ont tout simplement
enlevé à chaque fois Coupe du Monde au
Qatar c'est Coupe du Monde on sait pas
où l'Auvergne donc ils ont enlevé tout
ce qui était cathares c'est une énorme
darka franchement mais c'est pire en
fait
c'est une barquette
c'est le moment où le pays a revêtu ces
trois couleurs
la beauté du foot
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y a des joies que l'on ne contient
pas Coupe du monde de football 2022 un
événement à suivre dès le 20 novembre
sur TF1
et donc
[Applaudissements]
il y a plus rien c'est FIFA 2022 ça se
passe à la FIFA donc c'est un pays
c'est énorme franchement ça culpabilise
le téléspectateurs du coup bah bien sûr
c'est ridicule
mais dans ces cas-là s'ils veulent
boycotter ne diffusez pas oui
mais on n'en peux plus de cette
hypocrisie les gens qui n'aiment pas le
Qatar que ce soit les chaînes de télé ou
les villes soit vous boycotez à 100%
c'est ça soit vous participez et vous
êtes corporate mais vous pouvez pas
prendre ce qui vous arrange prendre les
revenus publicitaires et cracher dans la
soupe et pardon mais encore une fois ces
gestes symboliques à deux balles je
pense que ça a pas empêché l'émir du
Qatar de dormir de voir qu'il y a pas le
nom Qatar sur les bandes de TF1 ça ne
sert à rien c'est que de la colle si on
voit que certains annonceurs se
désistent et il paraît qu'il y a
certains annonceurs qui sont un tout
petit peu plus ça c'est la guerre de la
guerre
de la guerre je vais vous dire parce que
je vais vous expliquer un peu l'affaire
elle a raison Géraldine et là ça peut
être un énorme séisme
pour TF1 ça commence qui sont les
diffuseurs de la Coupe du Monde imaginez
deux secondes la Coupe du monde ça coûte
très très très cher de diffuser la Coupe
du Monde sachez que quoi qu'il arrive la
Coupe du Monde il part de l'argent vous
allez perdre vous avez perdre de
l'argent quoi qu'il arrive et même si
vous remplissez à fond les pages de pub
vous allez perdre de l'argent parce que
un match ça coûte très cher je crois
qu'il y a un match en moyenne je crois
que c'est trois trois quatre millions
d'euros donc vous rendez compte donc
trois quatre millions d'euros il faut
remplir avec de la pub si les annonceurs
donc les gens prennent des pubs pendant
les matchs de foot pendant la mi-temps
avant le match après le match disent on
y va pas
là c'est un drame financier pour TF1 et
M6 ça veut dire qu'à chaque diffusion de
match il perdent tous les soirs 3 à 4
millions d'euros parce qu'en juin ils
annoncer en grande pompe 330 000 euros
pour les 30 secondes de pub si jamais la
France arrivait en finale au niveau de
la mi-temps et sauf qu'aujourd'hui il
paraît que les annonceurs sont un petit
peu plus froids ils hésitent
éventuellement certains se disent à la
fin ça c'est une vraie à la baisse
sachez-le parce que ça vraiment
pour eux c'est dramatique ça veut dire
que là c'est rideau je sais même pas ce
qu'ils vont trouver comme comme
possibilité je pense que c'est pour ça
qu'il commence à dire on parle moins du
Qatar on fait c'est la police voilà mais
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que ce boycott il
joue contre TF1 contre M6 et ça peut
être extrêmement pénalise en fragile
plus les audiences il y a quand ils ont
quand même un doute sur leurs audiences
moi je trouve quand même que ça montre
la fragilité actuelle de TF1
négatif sur le kata et retire le mot
cata
terrible
parce que je vous dis vous voyez
toujours aussi des matchs de foot genre
la Coupe du Monde il y a 6 mois il y a
souvent des sponsors aussi oui vous
imaginez si déjà la Coupe du Monde c'est
sans tous les sponsors vous voyez
souvent on dit la Coupe du monde avec un
tel un tel untelia 3 4 sponsors voir 5 6
même parfois ça sachez qu'il paye cher
pour être sponsor donc si il y a pas de
sponsor il y a pas de ce qu'on appelle
de Billboard avant le match
euh vous voyez c'est avec deux ou trois
marques voilà qui disent TPMP avec ça ça
rapporte énormément d'argent si ça ils
l'ont pas parce que qui va être associé
donc à ça il va dire je voudrais pas il
y a plein de marques il va dire non moi
je veux pas parce que la Coupe du Monde
au Qatar avec avec
l'hypocrisie continue puisque vous avez
vu que ce week-end il y a eu la
présentation de la de la Coupe du Monde
la vraie la réelle avec Matuidi et de
saillie c'était où c'était à la Tour
Eiffel au premier étage en grande pompe
donc effectivement l'autorisation a été
donnée par par qui par la Mairie de
Paris et par l'adjoint à Hidalgo et là
ça leur a pas pour des problèmes oui
mais sauf que des problèmes elle me l'a
dit la fois
attention il est sympa
tu peux y aller alors vas-y